all right let's get to the mailbag
people loving the mailbag emails pouring
in about the mailbag
info
davidpakman.com is the place to write to
abuse it and lose it 120
viewers now auto filtered into
the trash because they are sending too
many emails okay let's get right into it
one of the best parts of when we stream
large live events like a trump rally or
a debate
or whatever
is lots of people looking for coverage
of that event who have never heard of
our show stumble across the stream and
this generally is a great thing it's one
of the fastest ways that we grow our new
audience
the
downside maybe it's sort of like a funny
you know it's a mixed bag is
people who are
right-wing nuts who stumble across our
coverage and then get really mad when
they realize that they are
um watching a left-wing stream and i got
a bunch of those i got a bunch of those
thanks to the trump rally ar rhoden
i can you're an absolute [ __ ]
i continued listening to trump's speech
but i'm sickened by your idiotic
commentary learn a bit of history you
[ __ ] you're more interested in
giving a commentary on the audience than
anything of importance in the speech
that's absolutely untrue and i take
issue with it can't wait to see you give
applause
during joe's next guard garbled
unintelligible lie ridden diatribe to
six people
um
i can't think of any time i've applauded
during a joe biden speech finishing with
your with y o u r y o u r it's almost
legally required in hate mail that the
wrong your versus your is used you're a
total
c word
sent from my iphone
um okay
so this this is one of the greatest
parts about covering trump rallies
people just looking for the rally
stumble across and are highly triggled
triggered trickled uh triggered and
people just looking for the rally are
stumble across us and go hey i like this
guy i'm gonna subscribe to the channel
um similarly mitchell wrote in in all
capital letters about our coverage of
the trump rally
who said mr pacman misspelled of course
as a conservative american i love my
country
i love our constitution and people like
you are a pathetic libtards
the way they love the constitution is
weird because much of what trump said
during the rally was completely
uh indicative of not caring at all about
the constitution
excuse me do society a favor i'm choking
over the words
do society a favor
and commit suck-eyed i think they meant
suicide
get the f out of my country
what a country we live in folks what a
country
uh don't know that there's much more
commentary to make about mitchell's
and then lastly
as many of you know alex jones recently
went after us infowars conspiracy
theorist going after me
for looking like a predator
and uh not taking live phone calls which
of course we do
he attacked the bonus show as well oh
the bonus show where you want to make
money everybody else that makes money to
find themselves is bad
yeah uh and here's a message from bobby
who was really pleased with the the
infowars segment watch infowars today
it was very sweet watching you get
completely busted on infowars
you are a total loser
suck it
a whole bs artist
what i love love love about that
particular message
is that alex jones is so diminished in
his audience because he's been kicked
off every real platform he's off youtube
he's off facebook
i can't even i think he's off spotify i
don't know um
he is he
he has almost no platform left so
at the end
i only got two emails
and one voicemail from people who saw
the alex jones segment and agreed with
him
it's it's really something how his
platform has just
evaporated almost completely all right
next is kate
kate has a good let's get now to the
substance kate wrote in
why do far-right republicans keep
burning things
hey david as a frequent listener you
piqued my curiosity when you mentioned
carhartt's vaccine mandate for employees
and how that caused right-wing customers
to burn their own clothing i couldn't
help but see a parallel
between this and the nike items being
burned and destroyed
after colin kaepernick protested police
brutality and racial inequality in 2016.
well also remember when they threw their
keurigs out the window why do far right
republicans keep burning things what is
this accomplished what's next books the
plan well but yes books the planet
they're already doing that i truly don't
understand this might be worth inviting
a guest on your show with a background
in psychology or something of the like
to discuss and investigate further thank
you for being such an honest engaging
source of truth yeah if anybody
i don't know exactly who would have
expertise in this but it would be very
interesting to speak to someone
uh who can explain
psychologically this phenomenon of
burning stuff
and the flame retardant carhartt clothes
impervious to burn attempts from their
very people it's i mean you you really
can't write this stuff
but uh a very uh
if anybody can suggest such a guest as
kate is mentioning we would be glad to
reach out to them
kristoff writes in about couldn't care
less david sir i watched your segment
today about the poorly capitalized
tucker carlson today show and his
misogynistic propensity for a
patriarchal society there was audible
cheering in my house when carlson's
guest said i could care less about what
people call him and you stopped the clip
to correct the statement absolutely
using that phrasing correctly drives me
insane because it makes zero sense to
the point of the individual supposedly
not caring it is very common to hear it
phrased incorrectly even by highly
educated people thank you for correcting
it why do you think it's so difficult
for people to use couldn't instead of
could for the phrase i don't know i mean
guys listen it's
think about it logically
if you could care less you're saying you
care
right imagine the phrase
i could care less
but i actually care more
so the correct phrase is i couldn't care
less i care so little
i couldn't possibly care any less
because i already care zero
please guys please go out there into
your communities and do what you can
to make sure that the phrase is used
correctly i appreciate kristoff
noticing
my commitment
to that phrase and quite frankly
i could care less about how the phrase
is used and by that i mean i care i hope
that that's clear to everybody steven
wrote in with an existential question
and wrote are traditional peanut butter
cookies actually candy traditional
peanut butter cookie recipes consist of
peanut butter
sugars eggs and sometimes vanilla is it
candy
um so i think the answer is no and i'm
going to give you two reasons why first
of all many peanut butter cookies as
their primary ingredients have peanut
butter and or flour
now i know that there are peanut butter
cookie recipes that contain no flour
and so
you've got peanut butter and then often
it's a very high amount of sugar i still
think that they're not candy i think we
could consider them junk food but candy
typically has as the primary ingredient
sugar
or chocolate like chocolate based
candies would have chocolate and then
sugar so i don't think and this is a
question of paramount importance i don't
believe that peanut butter cookies can
be qualified as candy
but i am uh open to having my mind
changed on that
all right here's a really important
email i got
last week during the tucker carlson
patriarchy jason whitlock segment i said
that i don't have any problem exploring
questions about men and women
that
they're you know
preemptively shutting down areas and
saying we can't talk about that i have a
problem with but
we need to understand what it is we're
looking to do with that information and
whether we actually already have the
information and claiming that we're just
asking questions as a way to troll
because we already know the answers i
got an email that from a female fan who
said david flirting with misogyny
david listen i just watched your video
called tucker guest says patriarchy is
good and i was a little put off by the
way you spoke about it sure you
acknowledged that the idea of a natural
patriarchy is wrong but then you said
you're open to investigating potential
biological differences like math
aptitude my goodness imagine you said
you're down to investigate whether
asians are biologically better at math
than whites
it's been investigated they're not
or whatever come on now i get that most
of your audience are likely dudes but i
think they can handle it no need to
coddle their egos in this way this is a
really sad email it is now 2022 and it
blows my mind even educated humans like
yourself are still saying s like this
just sounds ignorant sir i'd even say
you're flirting with misogyny i'm a
fanboy i'm a fan but boy that was
disappointing to hear i could not
disagree with this more strongly i am
against saying
here's a list of questions you can't
explore at all
you you just can't explore it i mean
listen guys
if it turned out women were way better
at cardiothoracic surgery for some
reason that didn't relate to economics
or
geography
or whatever right like if women were
just we imagine we researched it and we
determined there is something
inherent women are better at
cardiothoracic surgery
i would want to go to a woman for
cardiothoracic surgery now it might turn
out that because of historical
oppression against men in that field
this is a this is we're making this up
that there's really no there's a there's
an observable difference which we can
explain to discrimination i would also
want to know that
why would we say that can't be looked at
so i think it's very dangerous when
folks take this approach that you can't
even ask these questions the issue i
have is that these questions have been
asked for a long time and we have
answers to just about all of them and as
i pointed out there's no evidence that
uh
women are less capable for jobs other
than circumstances in which there may be
a physical limitation okay listen you
gotta lift 200 pounds and many men and
most women can't lift 200 pounds so
you're restricted to mostly men and a
small percentage of women who can lift
200 pounds okay we've got an explanation
uh but i i am very concerned about these
things where these things cannot even be
explored part two by the way is
if you explore things like this in a
fair way
the imperative is what are you going to
do with the information is the
information going to be used to
discriminate is the information going to
be used to insult
or or even worse that's also a factor so
i am not one of these just asking
questions people and every question i
ask is being asked specifically and in
bad faith to justify discrimination the
more of these questions that get asked
the more we learn
that discrimination is inappropriate
and it's wrong and it's unproductive
okay but
the email saying you you can't even ask
that
that that's not the left i recognize
that's not the left i recognize at all
uh okay last email here from william
offering pardons to the writers
isn't trump also signaling to future
rioters that he will pardon them thus
setting the stage for election-related
riots in the future
yes to some degree
so at the conroe texas rally when trump
said
um
first of all not only did he say we may
pardon some of the riders he also said
we're going to have some of the biggest
protests ever
sort of again alluding to more
violent protests because that's what a
lot of his followers want to do
um
he absolutely is
starting to plant a seed
about future potential repeats in
different contexts of what happened on
january 6th and uh his devout followers
know it they recognize it and it's very
very dangerous what we have to do is
prevent trump from being in a position
to be able to convince people to do that
send your emails to info davidpakman.com
uh we have a great bonus show for you
today sign up at
joinpackman.com and you will get instant
access to today's bonus show